saludos a todos en el día entero
[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a canadá en las
américas café o por su nombre de cariño
el castor cibernético los saluda paloma
martínez desde nuestros estudios en la
ciudad de montreal aquí en el estudio
vamos a ver tranquila estamos viendo las
imágenes que me encantan no cuida las
praderas canadienses pero acaban de
pasar unas imágenes de las praderas por
aquí en el estudio estamos con pablo
gómez
pues muy bien muy bien aquí
contento de que al menos haya sol hoy
porque ayer se desgajó un aguacero
espectacular yo no sé estaba durmiendo
y bueno pues sí cayó mucha lluvia ayer
pero hoy para estas grandes marchas que
hay en todo el país
alarte manchas del clima por el clima
por la urgencia climática que le llaman
también los jóvenes hay en todo el país
y bueno tuvieron buen clima para hoy
justamente buena temperatura no en el
clima se hizo cargo y acompañado con el
clima
exactamente les quiso ayudar a todos
esos manifestantes que están por todas
las ciudades las grandes ciudades
canadienses y hay que decirles que bueno
una de las de las chicas que lanzó más
bien la chica que lanzó estas huelgas
climáticas a través del mundo entero es
grieta tumba
la sueca la chica de 16 años solamente
está en la ciudad de montreal y estamos
viendo algunas imágenes ya de los
jóvenes que se están reuniendo sobre
todo jóvenes porque hay que decir que
las muchas de las comisiones escolares
de la ciudad de montreal cerraron hoy
para dejarlos a los chicos y que falta
así una falta sin motivo así que iba a
ser sancionada como tal en algunas
comisiones escolares en este caso
la de montreal creo que sí bueno y no
solo las escuelas sino hay varios
comercios también que cerraron para
permitirle a sus empleados de participar
en esta manifestación
exactamente entonces bueno esta es la
más grande de todo canadá la que tiene
lugar aquí en montreal están esperando
que haya alrededor de 300.000 personas
que se reúnan y de hecho el recorrido
que no es grande que no es muy largo va
a durar cuatro horas por la cantidad de
gente es lo que evalúa a la gente lo que
evalúan los organizadores e incluso las
autoridades de la ciudad que dijeron
desde ayer están diciendo que la gente
no debe desplazarse en autos hoy no
exactamente hay que mantenerse lejos de
las carreteras porque de las calles
porque van a estar llenas de gente
entonces le pidieron a la gente que
tomara el transporte público o su bici
pero es gratuito además es gratuito todo
el día de hoy o su bicicleta o que
caminaran simplemente pero que no
vinieran
porque bueno iban a encontrar mucho
tráfico y que después no se quejarán
dijo el alcalde
con esta movilización que es vestirse de
verde o que todo llevar un logo especial
que van a poner a disposición de la
gente para que lo primero pegarán en la
ropa para identificar a la gente
flores flores con las flores del planeta
donde parece que se está haciendo el
movimiento por eso toda la gente que
está ahí está peleando por eso no es que
yo sea negativo es que evidentemente hay
señales que muestran que si no hacemos
un cambio ayer esto se va a donde nadie
quiere que se vaya bueno pero yo creo
que todos podemos seguir haciendo cosas
en nuestra vida cotidiana
contribuiremos y eso es lo que están
queriendo hacer los jóvenes
greta thunberg fue inspiración para ha
sido inspiración para muchísimos jóvenes
en todo el mundo aquí en canadá
particularmente quiero mostrarles un
vídeo justamente de una chica de aquí de
la ciudad de montreal que se sintió muy
inspirada por greta se llama sofía
zapata y va en la escuela josep françois
pero que es una escuela de aquí de la
ciudad de montreal estudiante de
secundaria y militante de la gran marcha
por el clima escuchemos y veamos este
vídeo con sofía zapata
yo pienso que todo el mundo está en
picado en esta causa hace mucho tiempo y
cuando vimos de que esta muchacha en
suecia comenzó un movimiento tan grande
como todos los viernes también te falta
la escuela para hacer una manifestación
para manifestar pensamos de que era una
buena idea de que nosotros pudiéramos
implicarnos en ese movimiento los
jóvenes como el futuro y que si nosotros
nos comenzamos este movimiento que no va
a comenzar
lo importante yo pienso es de que
queremos que la gente tenga conciencia
lo que hace en el medio ambiente que
merece es la base de todo
el medio ambiente no tenemos nada
estamos viendo al gobierno de que tengan
nuevas leyes para proteger el medio
ambiente y que las leyes se cumplan
porque siempre dicen de que van a hacer
algo por nunca lo hacen jefe prefieren
que las plazas lleguen en otras partes
como en el petróleo siempre ponen plata
donde no hay pero no en el medio
ambiente nunca le ponen
y queremos que hay haga un programa
donde la gente comprenda que debe hacer
para alterar el medio ambiente
una participación ciudadana
entonces escuchamos la voz de sofía
zapata con imágenes de las
manifestaciones anteriores que tuvieron
lugar aquí en montreal y en otras partes
del mundo que son digamos las
manifestaciones que se generaron a
partir de la huelga que hacía a greta a
tumbar cada viernes en la puerta del
parlamento demasiado al facebook podemos
intentar verlo en el facebook de greta
yo voy a ver si pues aquí
y ahí es donde hay un montón de vídeos
si vemos no sé si no está desconectado
muy bien bueno lo que yo quiero decir
mientras estás buscando eso es secreta
tumba comenzó la marcha de aquí de
montreal hacia el frente fue la primera
línea digamos de la de la marcha la
comenzó greta iba acompañada de 15
jóvenes de la red de jóvenes de la
asamblea de las primeras naciones de
quebec y labrador que eso fue lo que
ella pidió ella quiso estar acompañada
por las primeras naciones canadienses
por jóvenes de las primeras naciones
canadienses y esta mañana a greta se
reunió con sus centros estuvo sentada
con ella en las fotos en las que se vio
que se la vio con con jüsten trudeau
estaba un poquito seria pero porque no
lo vimos el video bueno esta mañana en
la conferencia de prensa que dio en el
parque donde iba a comenzar la marcha
estaba muy sonriente greta y porque
decía estoy muy estoy muy esperanzada me
siento muy esperanzada de ver a todos
estos jóvenes reunidos a ver esta
movilización pero bueno las fotos que yo
vi con
centro do no la vi muy muy sonriente
ella lo supimos la semana pasada estuvo
presente en la asamblea general de
naciones unidos en naciones unidas no en
la asamblea general pero en las
instalaciones digamos de naciones unidas
y dio una conferencia y ella dio un
discurso bastante fuerte bastante
digamos mucha gente dijo estuvo
sermoneando a los políticos del mundo
estaba enojada y estaba triste en esa
ocasión pero bueno creo que el ver cómo
los jóvenes se movilizan en el mundo le
da esperanzas a ella y así es como la
vimos esta mañana en la ciudad de
montreal si independientemente de eso yo
creo que salieron a partir de la
exposición de grieta con toda la
historia del clima el movimiento que
está generando haya salido un montón de
gente a cuestionar el personaje y yo
creo que el personaje
no es lo importante lo importante
justamente en la lucha para que se den
cuenta de que esto se puede cambiar de
que el cambio se tendría que haber hecho
hace rato y no se hizo de que los
intereses económicos no son lo principal
es yo la semana pasada publique un
artículo de una persona trabaje
microsoft que es la persona que está a
cargo de todo lo que tiene que ver con
el medio ambiente de la empresa
microsoft y él decía que con la big data
se pueden cambiar estas cosas y se
pueden lograr los dos objetivos es decir
frenar el proceso brutal de polución al
mismo tiempo que generan dinero para la
gente que quiere el dinero porque
evidentemente acá hay algo que es mucho
más fuerte que la imagen de grieta que
es mucho más fuerte que pensar en un
futuro o en el futuro nuestros hijos y
en el planeta que les dejamos es pensar
que se nos muere hoy el planeta está
bien ósea y que esta gente por una
cuestión de dinero obviamente y de poder
y de todo lo que pasa por arriba de la
cabeza la gente que está a cargo no lo
sé
se pone todo el énfasis que hace falta y
no se promueven los cambios que son
necesarios
exactamente creo que eso es esa es la
lucha la lucha que traen los jóvenes en
algún momento se les ve muy muy enojados
y muy a digamos cuestionando todas las
acciones que no han tenido lugar que no
han sido hechas por los políticos que
son los que tienen el poder finalmente
de cambiar las cosas pero bueno a
pequeña escala la podemos cambiar todos
entonces eso es lo que también muchos
días yo lo que creo perdón palito una
cosa para agregar yo lo que creo que
sería interesante es que toda la
maquinaria entre comillas que está
detrás la grieta porque hay de está no
sale con su teléfono y hace todo lo que
hay tienen lo que es lo que vemos hay un
montón de gente que el aporte que está
usando esta es la cara visible para esta
esta campaña tan tan tan importante a mí
me parece que lo importante sería
también que no sólo los voy a estar
viendo los estamos cuidando también que
haber hecho tener que haber hecho esto
no es probamos el cambio
a alguna propuesta para hacer no
solamente estamos viendo y reúno cientos
de miles de jóvenes que se quejan por lo
mismo es nos reunimos para que esto se
cambie y aquí hay propuestas hay tanto
lobby de gente que le acompaña que
podría generar propuesta y no se genera
en esas propuestas porque es muy lindo
ir a quejarse pero quejarse y dar una
propuesta es mucho mejor claro bueno
pero en el caso de estos jóvenes que
están manifestando ahora
probablemente qué propuestas van a venir
un poco más tarde no lo que yo encuentro
interesante es que esta generación de a
partir de los milenios que les llaman
son mucho más reivindicadores mucho más
presentes mucho más activos que lo
éramos nosotros por ejemplo en nuestra
juventud
en algunos lugares y es de ellos
en méxico en colombia ha habido pero
esta implicación de los jóvenes de desde
los teenagers de los 19 años que los
adolescentes como que más activa hoy
ellos están reclamando las cosas se
están implicando y bueno pues eso es una
presión que se ejerce de alguna forma en
los políticos para que actúen ahora lo
que cierto es que todas estas
manifestaciones tienen que venir
acompañadas de acciones
por parte de los jóvenes también a
pequeña escala yo sigo insistiendo
porque muchos jóvenes dicen si los
políticos pero y yo sigo con su wii
sigue tirando comida sigo comprando
cosas que están sobre embaladas hay que
tener yo creo que una a lo mejor están
empezando a darse cuenta de lo de sus
propios actos y tendrán que hacer para
ser parte del calle y yo igualmente
ayuda hay otras cosas por ejemplo yo
miré con atención el último speech de
greta en la onu y lo que me pareció es
que está sesgado también o sea se habló
de la producción de carne y de como las
vacas contaminan
yo soy carol enloquecido y es verdad que
la contaminación es grandísima por parte
de esa industria pero hay un montón de
industrias que están las petroleras las
petroleras la semana en con también más
contaminan y de eso no se habló o por lo
menos cree está no dijo nada entonces es
como y el país donde donde cree está
viene tiene grandes intereses petroleros
entonces es como sí
a hacer el reclamo que el reclamo sea
completo los pequeños detalles como dice
paloma digamos el hecho de contribuir
con usar menos agua come menos comer
menos carne no dejar de comer comer
menos carne que creo que eso es comer
carne de lugares donde no se hacen
producción en cadena está bien de estos
grandes frigoríficos que son en realidad
los el lugar donde tienen las vacas
metidas allí que es lo que produce más
que libera más dióxido carbono o sea hay
medidas para hacer de parte de uno
chiquitas pero también es necesario que
se sepa que no solamente eso es lo que
provoca este deterioro tan grande de
nuestro campo y puede parecer también
muy utópico pero si hay que escribirle a
los políticos políticos están ahí para
algunos les puede escribir cartas uno
les puede decir yo necesito que ustedes
se comprometa con esto con esto otro
esto me preocupa ahora hay una chica que
está tumbar lo que es particular es que
no es la única joven que está realmente
implicada en movimientos fuertes y que
han tenido mucha presencia en todo el
mundo de hecho está aquí en canadá hay
una joven que también es muy inspiradora
se llama othón p no nos rompe el pie
ella es de una comunidad indígena de
ontario y othón pérez y ella se presentó
en una ocasión en naciones unidas ella
vamos a ver ahorita una imagen de ella
porque es linda su presencia porque
estuvo en naciones unidas hablando de
del agua ella lo que le preocupa porque
es preocupante para la mayoría de las
comunidades indígenas del país es el
acceso al agua potable que es difícil
para muchas de las comunidades
autóctonas y las zonas indígenas del
país entonces otto apel se dijo yo
agarro esta esta causa que es pequeña
pero es importante para mi gente para mi
nación para mis naciones alrededor y la
llevo lo más lejos que pueda entonces
ella apenas está cumpliendo hoy este
viernes 15 años pero tiene años me
manifestándose en varias en varias en
varios lugares en varias instancias
diferentes aquí en canadá en la onu como
decía entonces este fin de semana se
encuentra por si se presenta por segunda
ocasión en la onu y esta chica indígena
canadiense del que tenemos las imágenes
de esta chica indígena que estuvo
presente en la onu
ottón él sí tiene mucho por tiene mucho
camino por andar porque ella dijo yo voy
a defender porque los jóvenes de mis
comunidades no saben lo que es abrir el
grifo y lavarse los dientes y bañarse
con agua que salga directamente porque
no la hay esa agua viene nos traen unos
tambos de agua limpia cada semana pero
no nunca sale del grifo no la tenemos no
la tenemos disponible en muchas de las
comunidades canadienses creo que no
tenemos la imagen de la chiquita está
pero es una y es una presencia
inspiradora ahí la tenemos en naciones
unidas cuando estuvo en el 2018
othón p y ella además ven cómo va
cargando como una cubeta de agua y es
porque la nombraron las comunidades de
las naciones indígenas de su región la
nombraron comisionada del agua porque
desde chiquita empezó a preocuparse por
la cuestión de la voy a llevar la esta
preocupación a otros lugares del mundo
aquí tengo un mensaje gente que se está
contactando con nosotros mediante
nuestro facebook live en este caso en el
campeón en el campo link y dice hola
amigos son salidos de monroe en buenos
aires luchó para dice hola como están
después de anís urquiza que hay de
aquellos activistas que luchan por la
misma causa son asesinados por lo mismo
porque no se informa sobre eso dice
dennis urquiza miriam alarcón dice me
encanta que los jóvenes manifiestan en
contra del capitalismo salvaje a la
globalización de los inversores les
encantan las leyes medioambientales
laxas greta es una inspiración antonio
contreras francisco dice hay que plantar
árboles donde sea bosques disminuidos
montañas verdes saludos digo que todos
podemos hacerlo podemos plantar un árbol
en donde podamos en donde hay espacio
donde se pueda llevar cia dice que
importante que cree está venga de un
país con intereses petroleros a nosotros
la gente de a pie nos queda fácil
contribuir desde lo que está a nuestro
alcance en otros niveles la industria
también hará lo suyo el problema
es esperar a que sean otros los que
empiezan a hacer el cambio
y luego sí animarnos a hacer los s
rodriguez cherry otro de nuestros top
fans dice independientemente de las
críticas que se hacen agrieta lo
importante es comenzar a moverse a mover
las mentes y aterrizar en acciones
concretas las propuestas desde nuestras
posibilidades más grietas en todo el
mundo y danielle camporini dice que es
lo que no contamina hoy desde la
revolución industrial está sucediendo
esta degradación del planeta estoy
totalmente de acuerdo contigo daniel y
javier gonzález nunca dice saludos
cordiales paloma leonardo pablo en el
programa de hoy debemos hacer conciencia
de que ya somos muchos en este hermoso
planeta y debemos contribuir activamente
en ahorrar todo tipo de cosas hasta
mente ahorrar o utilizar menos recursos
menos energía y ahí hay algunas imágenes
de esta mañana de la reunión de la
marcha que se empezó a formar esta
mañana desde muy temprano aquí en
montreal y son como decíamos esperan
decenas de miles en esta marcha
climática en esta ciudad pero hay
muchísimas otras ciudades hay en toronto
y en banco
en halifax digamos en todos los extremos
y también en pequeñas ciudades en varias
de las pequeñas ciudades de ontario y de
quebec y de columbia británica habrá
marchas por todo el país bueno la de
montreal por eso esta grieta aquí es la
más grande de todo el país pero está por
todos lados jüsten trudeau que hasta
ayer había dicho que no iba a estar
presente ninguna de las marchas porque
estaremos en plena campaña electoral
finalmente decidió que participaba a la
marcha de aquí de montreal y como
decíamos se reunión aquí tenemos otras
imágenes de la marcha que están en
directo desde radio canadá desde radio
canadá desde la televisión de radio
canadá y ahí vemos también en el
reportaje a un lado a greta con el líder
de la de la asamblea de las primeras
naciones de canadá perry belgas que le
entregó un regalo diciéndole estamos
orgullosos de que usted esté trayendo
este mensaje a nuestras comunidades aquí
en montreal y bueno y como decíamos se
reunió con estos líderes indígenas el el
es el líder de la asamblea de las
primeras naciones que se reunió con
muchos otros de las y los jóvenes de las
amplia de jóvenes indígenas de canadá
perdón y con just en todo y allí está la
foto de greta con just entró dor ve que
les decía yo es el momento que no estaba
muy sonriente no está muy sonriente sí
igual
digamos que vivíamos dentro de este
personaje entre comillas por decirlo
alguna manera
tampoco quedaría muy bien que esté
sentada con un primer ministro de un
país que está contaminando bastante y
que se aludía con así con me parece que
ésta es parte también de realmente de
mostrar y de caracterizar que los
gobiernos no están haciendo lo necesario
sentarse con los que toman las
decisiones también es la estrategia
porque o sea muchas veces uno puede
protestar uno puede decir las cosas y
los que toman las decisiones no te
escuchan pero sentarte con ellos y estar
ahí pues puedes aportar tus puntos y
absolutamente a mí lo que me lo que me
dio mucha angustia fue él
es decir es una mala palabra porque
realmente me molesta fue la actitud del
presidente estadounidense cuando termino
creta de hablar ante la onu dijo a estoy
viendo una chica muy contenta muy feliz
sea tomándole el pelo con un nivel de sí
mismo e ironía tan tan tan delicado que
realmente el respeto es una falta de
respeto
aparte puntualmente a estos sobres y
aparte es una falta de respeto para
todos nosotros porque en realidad eeuu
es uno de los países que no se
compromete para hacer lo necesario
entonces solamente hablar del último
acuerdo internacional el acuerdo de
parís firmó entonces estados unidos y
china no creo que no habían dos dos de
los grandes que es rusia contaminadores
no me parece no se está india o china o
eeuu y uno más
firmaron los que se retiraron
fueron quien reactivó en eeuu la
producción de energía a base de carbón
es una de las más contaminantes o la más
contaminantes sobre el momento bueno
entonces vamos a seguir a quien en el
estudio vamos a seguir viendo las
imágenes de vez en cuando de cómo va
avanzando esta marcha aquí en montreal
pero también queremos hablar de otros
temas entre pablo te llamó la atención
una cosa insólita y burbara sí sí sí muy
particular porque aparte de ser muy
romántica quizá no romántica y además
como decirte medio enterrada
bueno esto sucedió
terranova en un lugar que se llama
corner brook que es una pareja bueno ya
va llevan viviendo varios años
pero el de él
el novio o el marido de esta chica
quería pedirle matrimonio entonces no
estaban casados todavía no estaban
casados entonces él después de vivir
muchos años con ella decidió de pedirle
que se casara
román a los otros posibles formalmente
pero no le dijo a ella que quería que
quería casarse sino que en lo que hizo
fue que compró ese sello ese anillo que
ustedes ven ahí como un diamante se lo
compró con el objetivo de pedirle
matrimonio a su novia a su amada era
llamada entonces pero él lo es lo
enterró en la hortaliza de la casa
porque están viviendo en el campo y
sembró semillas de zanahoria y como
vieron en la imagen
hay una zanahoria que creció justo en el
gusto
del planeado
de las cosas y les salió muy bien en
este caso a este muchacho que se llama
iván que tiene buena puntería y bueno y
ella dice que no entendía muy bien por
qué era que él la mantenía a distancia y
cada vez que intentaba pasar por allá
vivía solo además hasta el día en que
pensó tres meses más tarde después de
haber enterrado porque él enterró ese
anillo en el mes de julio y entonces
tres meses más tarde eso fue
recientemente esta semana él fueron a la
huerta y arrancó las zanahorias y en una
de las zanahorias pues estaba ese anillo
entonces fue cuando se puso de rodillas
y le dijo mi amor romántico y si y si
pasaba una ardilla y se robaba el [ __ ]
en el anillo que pasa en esas cosas
o sea en medio como loco el planteo no
le salió bien y ella dice que no se
esperaba a primero de matrimonio el
segundo de esa manera
y ya tienen hijos y todo yo vi verdad
que si viven juntos hace tiempo super
solo que nunca se han casado y ahora ya
decidieron se van a casar después de
esta linda y romántica pedida de
matrimonio
particularidad yo les quería presentar
lo que también me llamó mucho la
atención son dos hermanas de la región
de ontario de la provincia de ontario
que cruzaron canadá a caballo o sea un
viaje de 134 días de una esquina a la
otra esquina de canadá pero les quería
pasar el vídeo pero no se puede ver
entonces todo lo que existe es que
fueron de la costa de nueva escocia es
decir en el oeste
exacto del este al oeste galopando
durante 134 días al galope no tendrían
que digamos que fueron avanzando
avanzando sino fuera
golpe a galope hay tres o cuatro
estadios
[Música]
el que camina no es caminar
una pregunta para los oyentes los
caballos caminan
caminando es caminar o tiene otro nombre
el trote
bueno entonces esta chica es increíble
no animada 134 días así en caballo yo no
sé quién es
gente que creció nadando de continente a
continente o sea hay que tener ganas
solamente yo creo que ese es el límite
los casinos y las gentes que hacen esas
personas que hacen esos yo siempre yo
acá no sé por qué pero yo siempre trato
de ver el lado monetario cómo hacen para
vivir tienen no lo mejor obtienen
patrocinadores a fuerza también lo que
el campo me dice que cabalgar vez yo
decía había otro nombre
así que supongo que se acaba
claro pero no es claro que alguno puede
cabalgar al galope o que lo haga al
trote pero no se para
suponemos pongámosle cabalgar
lo más es de gustavo luca otro de
nuestro stop fans salud de la ciudad de
melo departamento de cerro largo en
uruguay dice como docente me preocupa
cierta apatía en los jóvenes jóvenes
como greta pueden aportar mucho al
cambio ese es el último mensaje pero son
cada vez menos apáticos creo y dolor o
la realidad yo creo que este tipo de
movimientos también hacen que el joven
tome más conciencia y bueno pues
entonces que le muestre imágenes de
estas grandes manifestaciones a sus a
sus estudiantes verdad
[Música]
esta semana bueno vamos a ver entonces
el vídeo de la aplicación porque tenemos
esta aplicación y otra cosa que quiero
la gente además invitarlos a que bajen
la aplicación que ahí está directamente
porque pierde está escuchando y
entendiendo cada vez más el español es
porque está entendiendo mucho españa
bueno hablemos de las plicas y
aplicación usted fue la embajada de los
dos de las dos plataformas más
utilizadas
es decir android y apple y en realidad
es una aplicación que facilita la
navegación por nuestro sitio donde
pueden encontrar todos los vídeos las
emisiones de canal las américas café y
los vídeos también lo pueden encontrar
algunos nada más sobre todos los vídeos
vídeos hechos en palpable los vídeos es
importante por el resto del equipo y lo
interesante es que es
bueno tiene un montón de funcionalidades
especiales como por ejemplo que no puede
guardar las cosas que le interesan para
leerlas después puede si tiene como yo
una gran presbicia puede aumentar el
tamaño de la letra para leer los
artículos que le interesan y es
significativamente más rápida que el
sitio de internet así que les invitamos
a todos nuestros oyentes a bajar esta
aplicación
buscan rs y en español y pueden
encontrarla en cualquiera de las dos
tiendas más populares en cualquier por
supuesto en francés inglés y español
exactamente entonces en cualquiera de
las cinco lenguas en las que difundimos
en radio canadá internacional yo digo
que pasemos ahora a los temas de la
semana porque nos queda poco tiempo y si
nos queda tiempo al final podemos leer
más mensajes pero como hubo varios
mensajes que vine a que vienen
directamente desde facebook live podemos
dejar un poquito de tiempo y presentar
nuestros temas del día
daniel camporini dice pregúntenle a
míster ed se acuerdan de mi historia del
caballo que hablaba
yo creo que no nos va a poder contestar
a dejar de estar bajo tierra por el
ministerio bueno yo les decía que vamos
a comenzar con algo virtual así es
porque leonardo nos habla de orissa lo
pudo plantear bien o lo plantear mal
yo quiero plantear mal digo cómo se nos
está pudriendo el mundo facebook anuncia
horizon un universo social virtual donde
el mundo es hermoso bueno y si no como
una revolución virtual donde uno puede
interactuar digamos es una red social
virtual la que está creando facebook en
este momento se llama horizon y para
todos aquellos que vieron la película
se llamaba rey de ready player one una
de las últimas películas de steven
spielberg solamente de eso se trata esa
es el vídeo promocional de esta nueva
red social que obviamente hay que entrar
con oculus que es uno de los productos
es una empresa que hace estos cascos les
llaman cascos de realidad actual que
compró facebook hace tres años atrás en
2016 creo bueno están desarrollando este
este escenario virtual donde uno puede
entrar y construir lo que sea y jugar
distintos juegos hacer búsquedas
relacionarse con gente
y por supuesto desarrollar su propio
mundo si uno quisiera dentro de esto
para poder hacerlo hay que comprar los
cascos está estas lentes se legalizaban
hay que gastar por ahora no es muy
barato pero se supone que una de las
grandes beneficios que va a tener
facebook es si entra mucha gente como
hace para que entre mucha gente bajar
los precios de la producción de sus
cascos virtuales así que en algún
momento llegará
el artículo les cuento de qué se trata
esta historia de hoy son un universo
social virtual que uno puede modificar
abordar o modificando en cuanto más
tiempo pases dentro lo más lo vas
magnifique modificando que hay uno puede
entrar en realidad cuando uno entra
llega aún a la isla es a la plaza esa
que está toda la gente empieza a moverse
y dentro de uno puede encontrar lugar
vacío y crear un mundo en ese lugar
único que puedes conservar y al cual
puedes regresar y clavo casa acto y que
la gente puede venir a visitarte puedes
intercambiar dentro del mundo que vos
creaste o sea realmente es modificar la
voluntad y esto pasa si ustedes ven la
película y sabiendo la densidad ready
player one es en realidad se llama oasis
en la película y es súper avanzado esto
es en realidad fantástico para nuestra
tecnología de hoy la película es una
película de ciencia ficción hay un
también uno de los episodios de la serie
d
netflix que se llama black mirror que
también es parte de un escenario virtual
ahora a mí lo que me llamó la atención
es porque no tienen pies
yo creo que para evitar complicaciones
en realidad
la mitad
es una muy buena pregunta y yo supongo
que tiene que ver con una cuestión de
movilidad dentro del mundo porque
él
en ready player one cuando uno se
conecta con los cascos tiene una
plataforma donde se mueve y se mueve
para estos lados no puede caminar en
este caso uno cuando se conecta no
camina o sea uno mueve con las manetas
vamos con los control remoto contra las
mueve el hace el movimiento porque uno
no mueve los pies aproximar a los pies
es muy probable que con el casco
moviéndote en tu casa te pegues un
porrazo contra una puerta entonces para
evitar que la gente camine tenga la
sensación de la necesidad de caminar
supongo que es por eso no no no estoy
convencido pero es lo que primero se me
ve la mente si tuvieras pie uno trataría
de caminar y cuando camina se deba a
puesta la mesa
pero me parece me parece que eso se
inspira de otro juego creo haber oído o
leído algo lo que había un universo
virtual en el que tú puedes ir y crear
un mundo no no hay juegos hay diferentes
juegos que se juegan de manera virtual y
en realidad la antesala de fe de oryzon
raid son convencionales
es espacios de facebook y salas ocu los
que eran lugares donde uno entraba
supuestamente con un avatar con una
personita no se identifica y esperaba
para poder participar en el juego y en
esa sala socializaba pero esto ya es un
mundo para entrar no son tan bonitas
porque los juegos de vídeo no sé como
los que hace ubisoft aquí el problema
que lleva muchísima más programación
muchísimo más tiempo muchísimo más
informática para mantenerlo andando o
sea debe ser complejo mantener toda esa
estructura con estos simples con estos
dibujitos simples estos avatar
hombrecitos o como quieren decirles es
bastante más fácil de recrear y aceptar
que venga mucha gente
bueno pues ese es el reportaje lo vamos
a encontrar en la sección de tecnología
de ciencia y tecnología que nos presenta
cada sábado así que muchas gracias por
esto y pablo tenemos mensajes
mientras se busca mientras se busca
esta semana nos hables de una historia
de amor con la lengua francesa exactos y
muy amorosos
la zanahoria como esta historia de amor
con el idioma francés acá de hecho es un
cineasta argentino un joven cineasta
argentino andrés libro que hizo este es
un documental un largometraje un
documental sobre una escuela de
enseñanza de francés para adultos
inmigrantes que han llegado hace mucho
tiempo
esa es la profesora lo hace lo que ya ve
en el movimiento que ella hace con las
manos y es quieren su apellido es lugar
pero hay que decirle a nuestros oyentes
que en francés un pájaro es falso
entonces lo haces como el pájaro y ellas
se presentan como
profesora lo hace y dice pero yo no soy
un pájaro yo camino en cuenta que en
realidad la diferencia es el apóstrofe
porque si uno es lo hace todo junto es
el apellido y el apóstrofe huaso es el
pájaro y al mismo tiempo le está
enseñando algunas reglas del francés
porque en francés cuando tienes una
vocal al principio le quieres agregar un
artículo entonces ahí entra la regla del
apóstrofo entonces es una historia bien
interesante porque
es la primera película que se hace sobre
este tema en aquí en quebec con adultos
inmigrantes y había yo no sé si ustedes
cuando llegaron hicieron esos cursos
cuando yo llegué aquí habían los famosos
coffee él carece de los centros de
orientación y de formación para los
inmigrantes que hay eran donde le daban
a uno esos cursos
pero todo el mundo lo llamaba coffee por
qué porque bueno era la francesa ción ya
y bueno y porque los cursos de francés
porque estamos en la provincia de québec
y aquí en quebec la lengua oficial de la
provincia es del francés y recordemos es
la ley de forma ley la ley 101 pero eso
viene más tarde con la elección del
partido quebequense en 1975 y por miedo
justamente de la desaparición de la
lengua francesa
aquí en quebec porque muchos inmigrantes
llegaban en aquella época
y se unían más a la comunidad anglófona
unidad francófona entonces por ahí eso
por eso fue que cuando se eligió al
partido que de que se en el c
boto esta ley la ley 101 que obliga a
todos los inmigrantes a enviar sus hijos
al francés a estudiar francés y bueno ya
hay cursos de francés para adultos
también y este de esta película que hizo
andrés es justamente sobre esos cursos
de francés y voy a parar ahí porque es
mejor que vayan
también a ver la película que se
presenta de los que están los que están
acá en montreal pueden ir a ver la
película incluso el decía que las
personas que estén en otros lugares
donde no se presenta en la película
pueden escribir y solicitar una
proyección entonces esa sería otra
posibilidad no sé en qué medida pueda
ser posible para nuestros oyentes allá
en latinoamérica bueno pero de todas
maneras la película está en francés y
tiene no tiene subtítulos entonces sería
para los que hable en francés
yo es la semana y yo esta semana les
presento un reportaje una entrevista que
hice con mariano lópez y mauricio pérez
mariano lópez mariano sí claro es un
psicólogo y pedagogo que estuvo con el
set
este mariano es de origen argentino y
mariano viajó con éste con la
tripulación del set nada en un proyecto
científico en el ártico en la antártica
lien y después volvieron acá el norte
también pero bueno ahora mariano desde
2007 2008 está trabajando con el circo
del sol con el proyecto circo y un mundo
del circo del sol y están ahora en
méxico esta semana estaban en méxico
dando una capacitación a capacitadores
es decir a gente en en el país en méxico
que utiliza el circo las artes circenses
para
a trabajar con jóvenes vulnerables en
situación de vulnerabilidad es decir con
mucha pobreza o con violencia en zonas
violentas entonces mariano me contaba
que este proyecto les es el trabajo
ideal para él porque le encanta estar
digamos con proyectos de querer cambiar
el mundo y al mismo tiempo utilizar
todas sus técnicas de psicología y de
pedagogía y estar siempre pensando en la
posibilidad de que aquellos jóvenes o
aquellos niños que tengan dificultades
en su medio digamos cercano pueden
encontrar en el circo otras
posibilidades como en aprender a
colaborar con otros aprender a tener
confianza en los demás aprender a creer
en ellos mismos en sus habilidades
entonces dice no es el circo por el
circo es el circo para cambiar el mundo
entonces se llama circuit mount y bueno
mariano lópez habló con nosotros y me
dio mucho gusto encontrarlo porque de
pura casualidad me di cuenta que estaba
esta semana en méxico y le escribí y me
y rápidamente nos pusimos en contacto
para poder comenzar entonces lo pueden
ver
en nuestro sitio internet nos vamos y
por eso entonces nos vamos a poner unas
imágenes de él de la marcha porque está
en pleno auge la marcha en este momento
la marcha por el clima y nosotros
estamos aquí en el loft en la oficina
cerrado encerrado pero miren ahí están
esas son las imágenes de aquí de la
ciudad de montreal cerca de la montaña
que le da el nombre a la ciudad del mont
royal donde están todos esos jóvenes esa
marea de jóvenes y de acá si es que
están avanzando a paso de tortuga porque
hay demasiada gente es lo que decían los
organizadores que la marcha comenzaba a
las 12 12 y media pero que el tiempo que
se iban a tardar las personas de
desplazarse desde dónde empieza hasta
dónde tienen que llegar en el en el río
san lorenzo iba a ser tan largo que
bueno no había posibilidad de realmente
calcular menos de 4 horas entonces bueno
ahí los dejamos con estas imágenes algún
mensajito así un mensajito cortito miren
al coro dice me bajé la aplicación muy
buena y vuestra voluntad es de
aplicación a aplicación con una sola se
dice yo creo que ya paz
dificulte por gustavo lucas
entonces los dejamos entonces muchas
gracias por habernos acompañado ayer
marc andré y benoit el otro lado de la
cabina muchas gracias y será hasta la
próxima semana
gracias años
[Música]